[Musique]
angoissant direction qui veut attendait
depuis des milliers d'années tu repasses
fabuleux terrain rue du pré mariage 3 et
ça la regarde
on dirait des peintures brillantes
études de la période précolombienne
et ça la regarde on dirait le bord du
fond bleu sur lequel on fait nos effets
spéciaux non
[Musique]
oui c'est ça c'est exactement ce que je
cherche depuis le début quand tu sais
que c'est sa tempe à la musique ça
forcément en rapport avec la laiterie il
faut d'abord que je fasse un flashmob
pour expliquer aux gens comment on en
est arrivé là mais on compte un seul
rebond 6 super simple le truc en fait
c'est qu'il faut répéter la dernière
syllabe de ta phrase en boucle quoi
[Musique]
1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
tu m'as pas laissé le choix de ma part
je te laisse le choix ce tu joues à
spirou alors se dit le suisse
[Musique]
or qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je vous
dise voilà dans la famille infogrames
j'ai fait papa j'ai fait maman et
maintenant il me reste le gosse a tardé
à laisser partir alors avant de
commencer donc je tiens à préciser qu
évidemment ce pierrot est tirée de la
bande dessinée avec spirou et fantasio
et que c'est aux héros qui me laisse
complètement indifférent
en fait j'ai découvert spirou et
fantasio parce qu'ils apparaissent pas
mal dans les premiers albums d'une autre
bd de franquin que j'adore qui
évidemment que gaston lagaffe comme
certains spirou lui-même je sais pas
j'ai une série d' aventure classique
mais j'ai toujours trouvé ça quand même
genre de soutien qui qui fait que ça va
tirer pas forcément finalement
concernant le jeu spirou il fait un peu
partie des jeux très gourmands je veux
dire quand on était gosses et que tes
parents voulaient offrir un jeu a vu
qu'ils y connaissez rien ils prenaient
pas des mortal kombat ou ou des trucs
avec des jaquettes un peu bourrine il
prenait des trucs qui leur parlait donc
c'est pour cette raison d'ailleurs que
pratiquement tout le monde a induit des
jeux comme les schtroumpfs tintin au
tibet par exemple et spirou bas c'est un
peu pareil sauf que comme c'était un peu
moins populaire que tintin ou lescheroux
va ça un peu moins marché le jeu spirou
sortie en 95 sur megadrive et super nes
il fait partie de la série des
adaptations de bandes dessinées de chez
un programme
il est sorti vers la fin après tintin
les schtroumps temps du soleil
et comme d'habitude puisque ça c'est une
vraie coutume chez les jeunes infogrames
on y retrouve tous les avantages mais
aussi tous les inconvénients des jeux
précédents mais là quand même on peut
commencer à râler un peu je suis désolée
autant de tintin au tibet il était sorti
au début c'est le premier y avait des
problèmes de difficultés extra d'accord
autant envie rousset bon après les
sorties 2 après et retrouver un jeu qui
est exactement le même problème alors
qu'il est sorti deux ans après ça va
quoi ça fait un peu chier quand même à
force alors déjà histoire d'expédier des
avantages de ce jeu va répéter
pratiquement la même chose que sur les
schtroumpfs donc ce jeu est beau il est
très beau graphiquement c'est impeccable
n'y a rien à dire que ce soit sur
megadrive d'ailleurs ou sur super nes
les animations sont fluides on y
retrouve le même si le décor que dans la
bd
donc voilà un niveau bon côté tout est
dit dalé est maintenant passer à la
partie amusante donc en fait ce jeu ça
il fait partie de la catégorie de jeu un
peu genre tortues ninja par exemple ou
en fait tu connais les premiers niveaux
parker tellement que tu les as fait et
refait en boucle à force de crever donc
le jeu c'est de la pure forme classique
ça ressemble énormément au jeu trouve
d'ailleurs on y entend souvent
d'ailleurs
bruitages que dans les roues
[Musique]
on a les premiers trucs spirou est un
héros de jeu vidéo ici et on sait tous
que les héros de jeux vidéo sur des gens
assez bizarre d'habitude prenez tintin
par exemple dans tintin le temple du
soleil l'autre jeu tintin à la fin ça
vous g sur super nes donc un passage
passage assez dur d'ailleurs dans le jeu
où tintin est bloqué dans un wagon avec
une valise qui roule ok sérieusement il
n'avait rien trouvé de plus péter comme
ennemi de taille de la valise on dirait
un petit sac à main
en plus c'est pas comme si la valise
bouger dans tous les sens elle fait
juste que glisser paisiblement d'un bord
à l'autre du wagon est ce que c'est
possible d'avoir une mort plus ridicule
que ça tué par une clochette mais non
c'est pas pareil tu peux pas préparé par
le bilboquet d'une petite fille oui mais
d'accord c'est pas un nom située par une
ombre nagl ma valise aller mieux
voilà alors je vous avoue que quand j'ai
vu ce niveau j'avais eu pas mal pitié de
tintin pour le coup maintenant pour
spirou alors même s'il n'est certes pas
aussi idiot que tintin on est quand même
devant quelqu'un de relativement qu'on a
un bon l'histoire du jeu donc c'est que
tu es censé poursuivre cyanure qui ont
levé ton pote champignac alors déjà
spirou il n'est pas stressé puisque
champignac il se fait enlever en plein
après midi mais qu'elle commence à lui
courir après il fait nuit donc là rien
branler pendant cinq heures bon alors ça
déjà mais quand même tu es censé la
poursuivre si un jour tu vas bien
d'armes et en poche et paf mais là le
mec il arrive devant un taxi garé sur le
trottoir au lieu de simplement passer à
côté pour attraper la nana qui a enlevé
son copain non lui il monte à l'immeuble
il prend une échelle ils s'accrochent à
des câbles électriques en esquivant les
pigeons qui lui piquent or les doigts il
traverse la rue à 50 mètres du sol bon
je sais que c'est vrai que normalement
les piétons n'ont pas le droit de
marcher sur la chaussée mais il ya
peut-être exagération lacan mais
maintenant que tous les courses
poursuites sont pas comme ça
[Musique]
questions pour ya des bons lierois il
est assez facile j'ai pas grand chose à
en dire il ya un très vicieux en fait
les vrais soucis de gameplay commence à
partir de niveau 2 dans ce niveau on
trouve un peu partout des espèces de
nounours qui servent de trampoline mais
là les versions super nes et megadrive
sont légèrement différentes en fait
regardez bien dans la version super nes
à droite on voit par exemple la présence
de décor en premier plan pour faire joli
bout alors oui c'est sympa d'utiliser
les capacités des consoles de la super
nes pour rendre le jeu plus jolie par
contre si c'était pour le rendre plus un
mais alors pas utile parce que les
décors en premier plan c'est sympa sauf
quand ça cache les trous qui est
derrière est regardé ça [ __ ]
et c'est pas le seul truc il ya plein de
passage dans ce jeu qui contiennent la
plus grosse saloperie des jeux de plate
forme c'est à dire les sauts de l'ange
alors ça c'est vraiment le truc qui
mérite le sceau de casseurs de couilles
officiel regarde ici c'est arrivé
marchant là tu crèves aucun moyen de le
savoir à moins de mourir au moins une
fois dedans vu que la plateforme elle
est trop basse pour la voir en se
baissant et même si tu arrive en courant
de toute façon tu peux crever aussi que
spirou il habille ses chaussures à savon
[ __ ] [ __ ] à sa mère lipopette
sérieux mais regarde moi ça mais c'est
pas vicieux safran joie de mettre un
trou qu'on ne voit pas juste avant le
panneau exit et mais je suis malheureux
pour vous et les mecs qui ont fait ça
ils devaient détester les gamins je
jouais en fait kadhafi il vit voiture
sort du magasin ça servait à quoi alors
ça vous savez ça me fait penser à un
autre passage de tintin j'y reviens qui
prouve que les mecs de chez fo g ils ont
vraiment une logique assez spécial déjà
on avait eu le coup du petit chinois et
d'intérêts au tibet là tu pars à la
recherche de tournesol tu le vois devant
toi à genre 5 m donc gbagbo a bêtement
je cours après parce que bon je vais
juste devoir mais non en fait faut pas
oublier que quentin 02 juin infographie
que cherche un truc
peu importe la loge il faut d'abord
faire un truc stupide et rationnelle
genre chez pratt est remonté un arbre à
moi j'adore ce genre de logique parce
qu'avec ça tu peux justifier ce que tu
veux dans mon jeu
son oncle est là pourquoi tu es monté là
chez pas un réflexe et dans spirou bas
c'est un peu le même genre de logique un
tiens j'ai été miniaturisé et si
j'allais dans un magasin de jouets pour
en chier encore plus
non mais il est complètement con ou
spirou là où koala bon niveau suivant
fantasio nous dit que cyanure et dans
une usine hors de la ville donc pour y
aller on doit prendre le le métro ok
donc c'est bien ça il est complètement
con qu'est ce qu'ils font sur le toit
c'est vrai que spirou c'est quoi ton
problème tu avais pas un euro cinquante
pour prendre le rer c ça quand ça doit
être super chiant la vie d'un héros de
jeux infogrames
on était trop con indécente au métro et
je te tuerais
[Musique]
ou alors je sais pas il voulait
peut-être pas monté dans le métro avec d
autres gens bons remarque ça semble
presque logique en fait puisque quand
ils pensent tous les héros de l'info
grammys awards avoir des problèmes
d'abord en folie seigneur mais où est ce
que je suis mon dieu mais regardez-moi
ça même à tarbes et un carton des fois
où sa patte approché à quelle horreur
parents des malades et 20 autres spirou
et tintin où le duo de choc moment qu'on
fait quand ils pensaient peut-être à
cause des jeux infogrames est
aujourd'hui que les roues sont
considérés comme des des gens très
intelligents et qui sautent bon
d'ailleurs ce niveau de métro il doit
être assez traumatisant quand tu es
gamin puisque c'est le premier niveau
vraiment dur de ce jeu en fait c'est à
dire que c'est le premier niveau qui ne
peut pas réussir du premier coup donc
c'est ici que tu va recommencer le jeu
une première fois tu es obligé de perdre
parce qu'il ya trop de trucs sur
lesquels tu es obligé de mourir au moins
plus de fois pour les connaître et donc
d éviter déjà un primo bon ce niveau
c'est le coût habituel du scrolling qui
avance
sauf que ici contrairement aux autres
jeux de plates-formes touché le
scrolling ça ne te pousse pas vers
l'avant ça te tue donc là déjà tu perds
une vie conan quand tu le sais pas
ensuite dans ce niveau c'est là
non sérieux et comment je vais prendre
le panneau là comment expliquez moi je
suis complètement derrière
[Musique]
en fait c'est assez technique a expliqué
mais pour résumer les animations de
spirou et son nez galante à se
déclencher et c'est valable aussi pour
le flingue à l'animation pour sortir le
flingue tirer et le remettre dans la
poche a fait pratiquement une seconde
c'est horrible et c'est aussi valable
pour le mouvement donc ce qui fait quoi
dans ce niveau en fait quand tu évites
les panneaux et coûteux que tu te
relèves la hitbox de ton personnage elle
passe directement du stade coucher au
stade debout alors que l'animation elle
un certain temps à se déclencher
du coup tu te mange sans arrêt les
panneaux alors que visuellement ils sont
derrière toi
alors bon vous c'est vrai que vous
pourrez me dire que perdre une vie ça
fait partie du jeu c'est vrai perdre une
vie dans un jeu de plateforme sait rien
normalement mais ici on n'est pas dans
un jeu de plateforme normal on est dans
un jeu de plateforme fo g
et quand tu parles vie là bas c'est
plutôt genre ça non je peur du vide
je vais faire maintenant c'est moi c'est
le père du devis aspirons besoin 33
ce jeu c'est un peu un genre de duels à
bord tu vois entre le le pauvre gamin
qui essayent de s'amuser le développeur
qui essaye de le courir c'est je sais
pas je ne comprends pas pourquoi ils ont
fait ça je sais pas mais parce que je
déteste les 1 face à ckoi plaidant est
même pire tu veux jouer la lonaci pour
toi ce puzzle je les ai tellement non
parce que quand tout à l'heure je
parlais de la gravité de perdre une vie
c'est pas pour déconner dans ce jeu
quand tu perds une vie je te jure t
blasé parce que niveau difficulté c'est
bon quoi déjà numéro 1 il n'y a pas de
checkpoint dans aucun des niveaux du jeu
dès que tu meures m6 à deux mètres de la
fin tu repars direct au début du niveau
ensuite numéro 2 y a que trois villes
seul moyen d'en regagner ses de
collectionner les chapeaux de huit ans
faut des cartons c'est 50 chapeau pour
une du numéro 3
y'a pas de continue mais tu sais que tu
le crois ça franchement pas de continue
même d'une tortue ninja qui était dur à
en crever y avait des continue et la lie
à rien au bout de trois vies ces fusils
allez on plie les gaules entoure l'écran
titre du numéro 4 le délire complet y'a
pas d'un mot de passe
le jeu entier fait 14 niveaux quatre
niveaux hyper difficile évidemment est
le seul mot de passe
on te file de tout le jeu du jeu entier
c'est après le niveau 6
même temps 2 2 au tibet qui est dans mon
top 5 des jeux les plus impossibles il y
avait des mots de passe plus souvent il
faut faire si niveau perdra moins trois
villes non mais c'est pas possible
autant ça serait juste de la difficulté
bon ben d'accord un tu sers les faits si
tu te concentres sur le jeu mais là plus
tu avances plus ça devient le bordel
mais jean le niveau 6 par exemple c'est
l'anarchie absolue quand tu le fais tu
te demandes si ya pas eu un changement
de développeur en plein milieu du niveau
bon écoute moi je dis ça parce que
j'avais déjà vu des jeux avec des règles
qui changent de niveau sur l'autre par
contre un jeu avec des règles qui
changent dans le même niveau ça j'avoue
que c'est inédit
jean par exemple ici des fenêtres tout
pareil là je peux marcher dessus
là je peux pas
un mur là je passe à travers et là je
peux pas des pizzas qui vole enfin je
suppose l'ag marche dessus et là je peux
pas non mais merde quoi
je crois vraiment c'est le passage sur
les pizzas qui sont les pires de ce jeu
là c'est bon là c'est bon oui oui fou au
[ __ ] mais c'est passage mais c'est du
pur jus pur hasard quoi mais un connard
de plateforme steam à eau mais c'est pas
vrai [ __ ] de bordel de merde mais ce
jeu mais ils me gonflent tellement j'ai
envie de l'insulter à d'allemands quoi
comment tu veux espérer passer tout ce
délire en moins de trois vies sérieux ce
jeu c'est comme une partie de jeu de
rôle sur table en fête le tir une belle
chance à chaque fenêtre pour savoir si
ça va marcher normalement
pour ceux qui connaissent un peu les
jeux de rôle sur table il y avait une
phrase célèbre c'était ça c'est
n'importe quoi ça assez bon ta gueule
c'est magique voilà ce jeu c'est pareil
cas ce que cessent de trucs mais c'est
n'importe quoi
puis ils ont fait gaffe 1 au cas où tu
réussisses quand même à aller jusqu'au
bout du niveau quand tu es bien en ruine
et quotas plus d'énergie juste là ils
ont bien bossé
voyez c'est à ce souci du détail c'est
là qu'auront connaît le vrai connard
sérieusement tels que vous voyez là je
suis calme je suis un peu pourquoi parce
que ses juges ce jeu je le connais déjà
donc j'ai eu le temps d'être youri zemma
colère mais je vous jure que ce jeu il
m'a fait taper mais des crises de rage
et de ce jeu et non pas que ce jeu en
fait tous les jeunes favorables
d'ailleurs quand je vois certains des
niveaux qui suivent je crois
sérieusement qu'un programme doit être
liée au genre de complot chinois
mondiale pour rendre dépressive la
jeunesse occidentale gens les catacombes
et le niveau il est rempli de pièges qui
se dérobe sous les pieds tellement vite
que t'as pas le temps de réagir
et en plus évidemment ils sont pas
signalés jeudi il n'y a pas de petites
fissures par terre pour te dire
attention là il ya un trou à narnia et
du tout aller c'est bien mourir une fois
dans chaque trou pour savoir où ils sont
allés ya pas de hasard là moi je suis
sûr que c'est une conspiration
non mais regardez ce graphique la la
hausse de la violence en france et
correspond à la sortie des jeux
infogrames et vous voulez d'autres
preuves regardez le logo d'infogrames le
tattoo la regarder ce que ça donne si on
ne renverse un tatoo à l'envers je crois
que c'est joué pour aujourd'hui
bref niveau niveau chez plus combien
dans la jungle dans les marécages ou ou
dans ton cul j'en sais rien enfin bref
écoute on va appeler ce niveau niveau de
merde habituelle dans les jeux de
plateforme avec les plantes qui crachent
des millions de noirs impossible à
éviter voilà un bon niveau là bien
schtroumpfs est bien relou avec des noix
qui tombent partout et histoire de bien
s'éclater même les plantes qui sont hors
de l'écran tu continues à te balancer
leurs trucs sur la gueule
la loi ce nombre de trucs qui dorment
quoi moi la balle je comptais vous
parlez de la galère que j'ai eu à
comprendre comment avancer personne je
trouvais pas ça logique mais après
chacun son point de vue je sais pas il
faut en fait il fallait trouver un
éléphant rose qui apparaît dans le vide
et qui chie une posture orange s'en
servir sur une plante pour la faire
grandir
et ici en plus du reste pour tdc que les
plates formes deviennent complètement
abstraite ça c'est vraiment un gros truc
chiant de ce jeu c'est que spirou ne
peut s'accrocher qu'en bordure de
plateformes du coup quand les deux
plates formes deviennent un peu plus
graphique comme ici avec des branches et
des feuilles et tout le bazar temps
permanence en train de chercher le bord
de la plate forme pour pouvoir s'y
accrocher et le temps de le tabla trouve
et internet
tu te fait pourrir par les plantes avec
les noix sérieux mais c'est chiant mais
ça je peux pas faire deux mètres ça
bouffe et doivent à la gueule enfin
nommé regarde moi cet endroit pour
récolter ces trois chapeaux là tout les
hommes en rouge c'est le passage du
noyau que de nature et tout ça c'est bon
on voit les noix ça me les brise non
mais c'est vrai j'exagère sûrement il
doit y avoir des gens se régale sur ce
genre de jeu
j'en sais rien mais là c'est trop que je
vais dire ok un jeu ça doit opposer un
peu de résistance pour qui le charge ce
soit intéressant mais la cca buzançais
punition ça je veux dire je vais vous
montrer le boss de faire c'est typique à
la difficulté normale du beauf s'ajoute
en plus une grosse incohérence de
gameplay
enfin me regarder à chaque fois que je
lui tiens dessus le rayon a l'air de
rebondir sur elle vous qui voyez ça
peut-être pour la première fois il
devait penser logiquement que ça ne
marche pas non mais je veux dire par
expérience universelle dans les jeux
vidéo quand tu es contre boss et que tu
effectues une action qui marche contre
le boss ya forcément un truc qui va
indiquer que ce que tu fais marche ça
peut être une petite animation où le
boss qui fait la gueule parce qu'ils les
touchent et d'effets sonores ou
simplement la base qui clignotent
mais d'ici là rien n'y a rien du tout il
ya aucun truc qui te signifie qu est ce
que tu fais fonction de donc forcément
au bout de cinq ou six tirs sur le mot
ça que tu as comme infos là tu dis que
c'est pas la botanique et une bâche avec
un prix pour la battre alors que dont
c'est la bonne technique c'est comme ça
qu'il faut battre le boss simplement les
développeurs du jeu ont voté juste trop
feignants pour simplement faire
grignoter le boss
non parce qu'au cas où vous l'auriez
oublié ici on est au niveau 14 et une
fois que des grippes vaut vivre portée
directe au niveau 7
ça veut dire que tu as clairement pas le
luxe de gaspiller des vies à cause des
conneries faites par les développeurs ça
c'est vraiment le genre de détail de
ruines le plaisir de jeu et en plus quoi
pour la faire on a juste droit à une
image au sérieux je vous jure si les
versions collector avait existé à
l'époque de ce jeu le cadeau avec spirou
ça aurait été une pour à la fin bon
cette fois c'est bon je crois on a tout
dit sur infogrames et sur leur jeu allez
dans la boîte verges à cartouche qu'est
ce qui m'arrive
qu'est ce qui m'arrive je me blesse
surtout non c'est pas vrai mais
transforme en héros de jeux infogrames
ça m'arrive
ouais mais bon c'est une malédiction
dont il ya forcément une solution là
dessous ils ont forcément laissé un
indice regarde rouge blanc rouge
oui voilà c'est ça la solution elle est
au pérou t'es pas d'accord si voilà
alors ce flashback est terminée en route
pour le pérou
attend il rien ouais ou alors un moment
j'ai compris c'est philosophique en fait
cette philosophie il n'y a jamais eu de
trésors en fait la réponse est là à
l'intérieur de chacun nous est en fait
il faut trouver la force dans notre
coeur deux absences étaient tombés par
terre regarde la réponse à la
malédiction des jeux infogrames satire
des mots ce truc si je marche sur une
pizza alors je passe à travers
je suis spi rouge tente dans des trous
je suis spirou et je suis fou tombe par
6 meur par l'avenir jours et pas pire ou
à les accrocher vous tant pis si je suis
plus rock que vous
spirou les rouquins c'est bien moi
sortez moi de là